the jurgen experience but
dude you're still rocking at the top of
the food chain
it's amazing i'm saying i'm people
people are saying i'm too old i'm 38.
well look at your victory over vicente
luque and then look what luke just did
to tyron woodley
you're still at the top of the [ __ ]
food chain because that was real
recently that you beat him
yeah it was i mean it was what a year
was
two years ago mm-hmm two years ago i
beat vicente
but uh yeah man people say and i'm i'm
i'm too old and
i guess once you get knocked out one
time you just they throw you to the side
that's people that don't understand the
human chin it's just like
it's just it's just a fact you can hit
with the perfect
shot it wasn't even hard it wasn't even
hard you know i've been hit harder tyron
hit me harder
jake ellenberger hit me harder this was
just right on the button it's crazy
isn't it to be honest with you it was
like it was like a relief
being knocked out i mean i've got close
to 80
something fights with kickboxing mma
together and i've never been knocked out
and
it was always one of those you know
league going into a fight
this is going to be it this is this is
gonna be the time i get knocked out this
is always going through my head
and now that it happened it's not that
bad it's really not that bad
i would rather get knocked out than get
just the crap beat out of me for five
five minute rounds have you ever been
knocked out in training no
so that was the only time ever in your
whole career you've been knocked out and
it was a
wild punch too the fact that he caught
you with a superman punch
i don't know man did the memes after
that with her or her i don't know if you
saw it but it was funny
you got to think though you've dished it
out so many times
i know you know through your kickboxing
career and
mma i mean there's so many times you
flatline people
and then uh yeah i get i get knocked out
by a guy
in a lighter weight class my dad my
family is pretty rough they
they bring it up as much as they can i
was in the hospital
that night and uh my dad's doing like a
face
book live thing because you know we had
a bunch of bunch of you know karate
karate families and karate kids there we
pretty much sold out that arena
greenville south carolina where i mean
everybody was there
to watch me fight and then i get crushed
or i get knocked out and then uh
you know everybody's want to know how i
am so i did it like it was probably 2
a.m
did a facebook live and my dad's just
eating me alive
eat me alive yeah i got knocked out he's
like yeah by a smaller guy too and
he just let me have it but yes oh man
that's how he is
it is what it is yep you know you you
took it really well
in terms of like the way you reacted and
social media and the way you reacted
when you were asked about it you know
show poise thank you thank you i mean
what can you do
i mean you can't just sit there and cry
about it no you know
uh yeah it bothered me for a while that
you know why did i not see it coming i
normally see this stuff coming
do you think you were relaxed when he
hit you is that what it was i think
it was definitely a distance thing
because when i when i had psychic i
watched it over and over and over again
i don't remember any of the second round
i don't remember any of it all i
remember
is getting up off the stool looking
across the the cage and i seen his
bloody nose he's banged up and i'm like
all right time to time to pick it up
i'm gonna finish him this round this was
going through my head that's all i
remember and i got knocked out
five seconds left in the second round
wow i don't remember anything i remember
sitting up
talking to him in the cage the people
say i was like high-fiving people as i
was walking by
all i remember is like these sparkles
kind of fade away and i see chris
weidman's face
right there he's laughing at me he's
like smiling at me and he said if you
ask me that again i want to slap you
i guess i asked him the same question i
kept saying you know what happened how
did i get knocked out i got knocked out
just kept saying that's what people do
when they get knocked out they
they ask the same question what happened
over and over again it was such a weird
thing
and then you know not remembering any of
that
and then just being in the back it's
like i got teleported there
i was fighting and then i was there and
i remember him helping me trying to
answer the doctor's questions they're
like you know what day it is
i'm like uh chris is like stephen come
on you know what day it is he's like
trying to help me out answer these
questions
but uh that's all i remember man is is
that but uh
it was a relief like i have nothing
what else i mean that's like the worst
thing that can happen why why why do you
feel like it's a relief
well you know it was such a worry you
know i've knocked out people i've i've
seen how they are
you know getting up off the canvas and
the the
you know what it's done to people
psychologically
getting knocked out and that's always
been kind of like how would i handle
that
you know how would i handle that how
would it how would you see people get
knocked out and they
they try and come back maybe as soon as
possible which is not a good thing
it's a terrible thing yeah they should
give their time you know time for their
body to heal up but um
you know i've seen people do that it was
always a worry for me how would i handle
that
yeah i always get concerned when i see
someone who gets knocked out they want
to get right back in there and like oh
you're asking for trouble because you
might feel fine but you probably are a
little loose
yeah it's funny you said that because
they ufc wanted me to fight
wanted me to fight two months later in
my hometown wow
and after the day after was going to get
some breakfast with some with some
friends
um still in knoxville with a fam
and i get a call from um dana i think
was hunter
hey man you still want to fight in
greenville south carolina
of course the athlete and myself said
yes like i wanted to jump back in there
and yeah
but then you know reality kicked in and
you know i look over at my pops and he's
like the he i think he already know who
it was he said
he just shook his head who was it that
you were supposed to
um i don't think we had anybody the usc
should have made it
anthony pettis mm-hmm it was only like
two months later
it should have been anthony pettis in my
hometown but um
and i didn't find out that the ufc was
in greenville i found that out
watching some fights like uh so you've
seen this before ufc should have made a
rematch
with anthony pettis or you should have
had that should have been when you
fought pettis yes it was in your
hometown
yeah we would have sold that out catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience